would you fly seven hours to see elderly
relatives for holidays
then stay with family in a hotel for two
days is this unsafe given the pandemic
note that the destination state requires
a test or 14-day quarantine
so i i included this not because i think
we can answer it because i think you
just
you need to know more about everyone's
risk tolerance and
the particularities of how careful
people are being and and
and all of this but um i i wanted to
just say this out loud
because i suspect that this is something
that a lot of people are wrestling with
uh right now as as the holidays approach
um
you know how is it that after gosh
two-thirds of a year of almost
yeah almost of of some
combination of lockdowns and just you
know complete
disorder at almost every level of of
life
uh how valuable
are the the shared
memories that you would create around
holidays together which is so
often the time that families see each
other who don't otherwise have time to
see each other
you know what what is a break you know
for people who have an annual tradition
for whom that that part of the annual
tradition has actually not yet been
disrupted what might disrupting
regular traditions that occur at that
level of sicklicity
due to further cause disorder
and i i don't know but i think it's
potentially big
i think that there's been so much
disruption this year but there's
like tether on the holiday season that
can mean a lot of different things for a
lot of different people for some people
it's thanksgiving for some people it's
christmas uh for some it's you know
hanukkah isn't a real holiday but um but
you know it's
it's a minor holiday i i know i didn't
mean not real but
um you know for for most people there is
some
holiday at the end of the year that
feels like the thing
that uh that they experience that they
that they return
home for the solstice
and giving up on all of that
may create even greater
mental health disruption than we've than
we've yet seen
that said people often complain about
the family time around holidays
um and you know missing it might
actually reveal
that it wasn't as bad as you thought so
you know there's a lot going on here and
i don't know the answer
yeah i think a it could be very
hazardous
in the sense of the annual check-in
that people typically experience may
have a calibration
function that we don't missing it could
be hazardous is what you mean absolutely
um obviously there's a huge danger of
uh you know a
not a super spreader event but a super
spreader moment where people
are gathering and suddenly
versions of the virus are spreading
around which could be
hazardous in its own right one thing i
would say that i think
we have been discovering of late is
this is actually a perfect model for
what we were talking about before
about the oscillation between left and
right at the moment we have
two narratives about
virus and carefulness surrounding it
both of which are wrong and
the the
little bit of travel that we have just
done and the
gathering with people where we have seen
very few
outside of our immediate circle for
you know two-thirds of a year has
revealed that there's a
problem also the change in season
all of these things have revealed that
there is a problem with
the fact that we have not reached
agreement on what we are trying to
accomplish and therefore
how to collectively make good decisions
in other words
there should be some discussion before
you gather with people
about how you're going to minimize the
chances that if one of the people at the
gathering
has covered that it will not spread to
others in other words is there an
opportunity
to meet outside what is the
code of conduct with respect to masks
does the fact that i'm not wearing a
mask while we are meeting outside
mean that i am against masks no so
you know basically it would be great if
a socially distant group
outside didn't wear masks because
they're unnecessary
put them on without anybody having to
remind anybody as you go indoors
that you spend as little time as
possible
in very enclosed spaces you prefer rooms
that are
larger you prefer windows that are open
you prefer fans that are
on yeah it's really tough to do for most
of the country though in november and
december
right so what that means is that all of
these things have changed and so what
we've discovered is that we had a really
good
pattern that we were all in on
and it just became we the four of us and
our family here our immediate family had
a pattern where you know we had we were
making use
of restaurants always outdoors
right and we you know we were very
careful about
windows and things when somebody came
into the house
and the problem is the weather is now
taking the
behaviors that we're working and
upending them
and so what that's resulting in is a
kind of since we're not in the frame of
mind of thinking about cove at every
minute of the day anymore because
we've just gotten used to it we're now
you know
thinking well we're not even thinking so
it's the idea is that restaurants
were possible because outdoors was safe
and it isn't highly transmissible
in food so um
the temptation is you know we're back in
restaurant mode where the restaurants
are a possibility but
they may again not be a possibility
based on the fact the weather means that
outdoor dining isn't happening anymore
so all of these things require
sort of a rebooting of the conscious
discussion
of how can we prevent each other from
getting coveted if somebody brings
it to a gathering and this is much more
important than some fraction of the
population
seems to believe at the moment based on
the dire consequences for some people
who get this thing these months and
months and months of
you know myriad different symptoms yep i
will say that um
on our recent uh just four day trip uh
to
uh a place even farther north than we
are now
uh we went to eat outside in a mexican
restaurant and it turns out that despite
what their website said
they were only open for takeout but they
were selling margaritas to
drink while you waited for your takeout
so we sat outside
and drank extraordinarily cold
margaritas under a very cold sky and
darkening sky
and i thought this is not the conditions
under which margaritas were invented
this is not this is not the right
circumstance to be drinking margaritas
at all yeah but the food was freezing
your ass off in margaritaville
exactly exactly